un vendredi festif annie vignola
profitent des derniers jours avec ses
enfants car la rentrée scolaire
s'annonce mouvementée elle n'est pas
certain d'avoir accès à un service
d'autobus pour ses deux aînées on
espérait bien en fait que les gras les
propres en autobus parce que les gars de
russie ces conflits qui fait qu'on a
deux gars d'expérience plus les écoles à
manager avec deux emplois ça va être
beau
95% des contrats en transport scolaire
sont arrivés à échéance à la fin du mois
de juin il sarda être renouvelée entre
autres dans les régions du grand
montréal de lanaudière et de la
montérégie
les négociations entre la fédération des
transporteurs par autobus et le
ministère de l'éducation achoppent les
transporteurs demandent une hausse de 25
% des tarifs
les résultats ont été
déposés comme sa discrétion en joie ne
sont pas suffisants pour permettre d'en
stocker de couvrir l'ensemble
à la coopération et faire soucis aux
fluctuations
jours au brusc murs ou des pièces ou la
conséquence de l'impasse de près de
trois cent mille élèves pourraient ne
pas avoir de transport à la rentrée le
gouvernement reste confiant il y avait
beaucoup de contrat qui arrive à
échéance au printemps dernier on le
savait donc on avait obtenu des fonds
supplémentaires ma part de finances est
présent au gouvernement pour tenir
compte de l'inflation et du coût plus
élevé du diesel donc on a déposé des
offres bonifiées et les négociations
avancent de leur côté les centres de
services scolaires assure aux parents
que toutes les écoles offriront les
services éducatifs comme prévu au
calendrier scolaire néanmoins ils
analysent actuellement des pistes de
solution si ça va bien mais ça va être
un cadeau mais on
déjà des plans b puis s'épuiser il reste
deux semaines avant la rentrée des
classes et même si le gouvernement est
convaincu que les contrats seront signés
d'ici là avec la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans le secteur du transport
scolaire les familles ne sont pas à
l'abri d'autres perturbations il si
charles du boullay radio canada montréal